how's it going rejects we just
watched bill and ted 3 face the music
we actually did a reaction to it it's
just a watch along where you sync up
with the time code we thought it'd be
fun if you guys wanted to check that out
there's a link in the description box of
vimeo link you should be able to
download
if you want to make life easier for you
so we have a reaction there
because we did quite enjoy this movie a
lot we're going to do a review for you
guys
right after this intro but if you want
to do a watch along go to that
description box and pin comment
and then meet us back here
[Music]
so yeah we just saw bill and ted 3 face
the music here's the plot from imdb to
make life easier
once told they'd saved the universe
during a time traveling adventure
two would-be rockers from san dimas
california
find themselves as middle-aged dad still
trying to crank out a hit song
and fulfill their destiny along the way
they got marriage problems
they have got kids they got kids
adequacy to deal with
also uh are trying to mainly save their
own asses
by trying to steal from themselves in
the future so you run into
a lot of really wacky music based
adventures
i gotta say this movie is pretty much
exactly what i wanted
everything i've been saying from any
trailer reaction you guys might have
seen from us it 100
delivers here both keanu reeves and alex
winter returning in these roles is
really funny and i thought they did a
really
great job working with how they've aged
and still keeping the personalities
where we last saw them in bogus journey
but it doesn't have that odd effect kind
of like dumb and dumber too
doesn't seem like they're really working
with the fact that they've aged at all
so it just seems like they're
trying to be like how they were decades
ago they've really let them age but
still kept that
bro dude personality from them
yeah and they make it an obstacle for
them to overcome even i think that's
something that really helps this to work
is that bill and ted have always sort of
been
on the edge of being failures in various
ways and that's part of the fun
is watching them try and you know
triumph
yeah i mean keanu reeves brought me some
huge laughs you see a lot of different
versions
of them throughout this film and i
really liked every single time keanu
reeves was embodying a different version
of 10. yes
he really had a lot of fun with that and
they seem to take a bit of a
psychological approach
with not too heavy it doesn't go like
way in your face and they're trying to
be the
super deep movie but with having this
element of
heart and a little bit additional nuance
based into the psychology
of these guys actually does elevate it
just a tad bit
more above the others in terms of the
character department
yeah i think what really really helps
this to work is the fact that they do
take bill and ted and play them for
genuine characters and i think part of
the magic of the series overall but
something that carries heavily into this
movie is a
keanu reeves and alex winter just have
such chemistry and they both really
commit to bill and ted you can tell that
they're not judging the characters
they're just being them and also chris
matheson and ed solomon who i guess
created the characters like in an improv
group
way way back you can really tell that
they care about at least having them be
characters with actual things to deal
with even if those things are
whimsical or goofy aging is almost a
happy accident for the franchise because
it gives them plenty to work with you
have these two other characters in here
played by samara weaving
and then bridget lundy payne thea and
billy
uh they are the daughters of ted and
bill
and they are great i especially love
samara weaving they're both
great but samara weaving really stood
out to me a lot in this one and i feel
like they do give her a little bit more
of a lead and a little bit more
differences in variation with her
delivery yeah you know
she's a bit more of the thrust and then
bridget lundy pain is just
full like she is like full tetting it in
this movie in a way that i
yeah i really enjoy it you see them a
lot in the trailers and uh i love their
chemistry i love their level of support
and you got a whole bunch of fun cameos
in here
uh from all kinds of different musical
artists or like portrayals of musical
artists and maybe there's a couple of
real
musical artists in here and they always
had a really nice surprise with them
this movie
added so much more heart to it than the
other ones
uh kind of like what we expected for it
it was pretty much my trajectory of
my experience of the film the first 10
to 15 minutes really funny and then
there were some jokes that started to
kind of like fall
a little bit flat but once the adventure
really started to kick in there started
being a lot of really nice surprises
there's this
robot in the movie i don't want to give
much away about it that's the thing is
there's so many surprises and fun little
details and surprises on how they
execute things
exactly yeah because there are a lot of
times where it feels like the movie
could be oh trying to appeal to now
and they really cleverly avoid those
things like that yeah because it feels
different than the other two the
direction
in terms of how it's captured and edited
and the way the scenes play out this
is the director of galaxy quest and i
definitely got
a lot of that same kind of sensibility
and some in the production values too
especially when there's a lot of cgi
the other ones had a bit more of a
raunchiness to him that's true
and this one really doesn't no
and and actually not at all now that i
think about it yeah really and it's
funny to me
because yeah i didn't even miss it and
partly too is just because it naturally
feels like oh yeah but bill instead have
just gotten older
yeah and they are so dedicated to their
wives and trying to please the
princesses and they have
i think giving them daughters was a
really nice touch and again it doesn't
have the ranch but it also
isn't bill and ted go to woke school
it's not distracting at all that it's
missing and it feels like yeah a new
iteration of bill and ted but also a
very natural
follow-up to what has come in the past
and i thought they did a really nice job
in coming up with their own game for
this movie what's gonna be the kind of
repeat gag but
also nodding to the historical figures
of the first film heaven and hell from
the second film and really bringing all
that
into one big what feels like one big
world you know trilogy well the stakes
are a lot higher here compared to bogus
journey
there's effects of greatly updated yeah
and they're
just good actually the hell sequence was
really surprising in terms of like wow
they
really painted this they brought
there's also some surprisingly amazing
makeup work in this movie there's some
of the best old age makeup i've ever
seen in this movie
there's makeup work in this that kind of
shocked me on how
detailed and intricate it was william
sadler reprising his role as death he's
still got it man
yeah so funny and they changed some of
the dynamics just because they kind of
update you a little bit on what
what happened after bogus journey with
them the way they've kind of shifted his
character around but
the delivery and the comedic timing it's
still so sharp it's still so
there yeah and this movie is not only
nostalgia based and the thing is it
feels kind of like a family film it's
and if
it's about family and it doesn't have
that juvenile humor
and like you said because i didn't even
realize that until we started talking
about it right now
because we haven't talked about it at
all since we watched it yeah we just
started filming this
there's a celebration quality to it the
whole thing with the music
really is felt there's plenty of times
we're just like dancing along
with this feels like an event and i kind
of wish we did watch it at a theater or
a drive-in you know well yeah and i and
i think what for me
that quality is is that it just really
exuded a
love like i really felt like keanu
reeves and alex winter
wanted to do this the fan like i can
tell that this is like
to me kind of the better or the best of
what fan service can offer you because
it seems like everybody wanted this and
they
definitely at least from interviews took
their time to crack the story and make
sure they had the right reason to come
back and people say that a lot but i
really
felt it here because yeah there is just
so much love exuding from the movie and
even the stakes like it's not like the
second one where you have like a villain
figure per se and they also avoided
things like making their daughters like
really snide and hate that like there's
so many things they could have done
to make it more edgy or more now and and
they really just led with
we all love bill and ted we want them to
succeed succeed
they're oafs so we know they're gonna
get into some high jinks along with you
really feel the ticking time clock
yeah it's very obvious the movies run
times
the movies are on time it is and i feel
like they really constructed it to the
run time which is pretty crazy you know
in movies
like a small example can be like oh we
got 30 seconds so the bomb goes off and
you're like five minutes have gone by
yeah yeah
exactly but it seems like the movie is
perfectly timed even though you're
hopping around time it seems like
whenever they check in with how much
time do we have left to deliver this
song
feels like it's in real time for these
guys they're better at budgeting their
titans so they don't have to remind ted
to wind his watch in this one i think
they do a
a really amazing job at surprising you
with
how they can flip tropes here and there
yes there are some hilarious examples of
that here and while it does deliver on
some things that are a little bit
predictable and nostalgic
towards like the first bill and ted
especially there are some
jokes yeah there's some running jokes
that continue through even the thing is
i feel like you do
essentially have to be at least a bill
and dead fan to like this movie
oh yeah you know it's different i don't
feel like it would upset any fans
you know that's that's the thing that's
what's great about it is while it feels
different than the other two
i can still see fans of those two being
like oh yeah this one's really good too
it's a good
capper to the bill and ted truly yeah it
feels really appropriate and again it
does
so much stuff to broaden out but to also
keep it in the family and it has the
quality that the first two movies have
where it's compact and yeah there are
some moments that aren't as
amazing as others but in the end the
movies are kind of like bill and ted
themselves they're jovial and fun and
imaginative and yeah sometimes they're a
little
goofy but ultimately they really know
the soul and it really shows
yeah like i was just smiling from ear to
ear it was it was a really big laugh out
loud experience throughout
yeah yeah and and after a weird week in
the world like it
it made me feel joy in the way like the
love of cinema makes me feel joy
you know all right guys well did you see
bill and ted face the music leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
catch you later
[Music]
you